the face of it is a million dollars
meaning your collateral i'll give you
800 000.
some people would say i'll give you 500
000. others will say i really like it i
want you to make it a little bit bigger
i'll give you 1.2 million
how does the money come together for one
of your projects
um
you know it in a couple different ways
um
normally
uh someone
you know will
will send the script out and then and
just we have a network of
sales agents and distributors
and as long as we have an actor on the
film that they like
and that they can sell
they'll give us a
minimum guarantee
and and then we have places that we can
go take that minimum guarantee and
and cash flow it depending on who that
comes from we can get between 80 and 120
of the face of the minimum guarantee
thing about filming in mexico what
happens normally i'll back up just a
little bit is that you'll normally that
mgm out will not be enough that's why
people go to the rebate states because
then they can go get you know about
another 30 percent or so which will
complete their budget maybe they have a
little bit of cash or an investor an
equity investor
generally speaking we can keep our
budgets low enough to to to
work just with what we have with the
minimum guarantee
which is why we're kind of unique in
that way
what they give us with the minimum
guarantee we make the movie with that
whether it's the
you know 80 or 120 percent sometimes
there's a little bit of money in there
with you know gap money
but um generally that's the way it works
and sometimes you just have people that
just have money
and they
come down and
want to make a movie
and then but but we like to that's the
rich uncle um program
isn't really one to build your career on
in my opinion you wanna you wanna have
the right connections
and the know-how
to speak the language of those
distributors and financiers
you know we have this person
this package we have these people we're
going to film it here here's the budget
here's the schedule and then we've done
it a million times
and then they say okay cool they give
you the paper and once the paper is
collateralized there's a lot of people
that will
will um
will you know give you money for it's
like if you go to
we're selling uh you know
paper cups and we get a um
order from walmart
for a hundred thousand
paper cups someone will give you the
money to make those cubs
you know the key is you have to make
sure that it's the right price and you
know how to make the cups and things
like that but once you step once you get
the the purchase order from walmart's
any a lot of people give you the money
to make make it as long as you know how
to make it so it's kind of like that
you said previously uh we all need to
know about the sort of the law of supply
and demand yes
so
is there like a crash course you could
you could teach and well
um
yeah that's i tell i tell that to a lot
of people actors especially because
actors
sometimes will say hey i'm worth this
much money and i want this much money
i'll say well i love to pay that money
but we're all
subject to the laws of supply and demand
and if
if if i go to
germany
japan
and um italy
and i say i have uh joe blow in my movie
i'll whatever they tell me i'll give you
half of it chances are going to tell me
i'm not going to give you any more money
for him or her
and
so so i have to sell the film so i
understand your services or your
services but i can't pay you premiums
that i can't recoup
this is the laws of supply and demand
and
oops and you know we'd love to make our
art and our wonderful films that we
have in our minds
that we have thought about and dreamed
about making but at the end of the day
we have to
um supply what is in demand
and
and that's the difference in my opinion
of working a lot and working
a little
and it will be
you know maybe
in the end of it
it'll be that wow you should have just
made two great films and not 20
cool films
maybe that's what maybe that would
be if there was a alternate universe but
the path that we've taken is one that
looks at what is in demand and helps to
figure out a way to supply that demand
so that
so that the so that the train keeps
moving down the tracks the the enemy
of the process is
is to not be moving
you have to keep moving
uh
even if it's risky
even if every project and let me tell
you every project is not a good project
of the 28 29 projects we've done
everyone has not gone great there's been
and and there's no one else to blame but
us or me
and some and those can be hard to come
back from sometimes
but you know you don't do 28 films and
have them all be perfect it's just not
going to happen
the key is keep moving you keep adding
value you keep
making sure that
the what you provide
you know in the end
gets finished and is put out into the
market it's success level you really
can't
help or or say too much about it has a
lot of different factors but make sure
that the quality stays very consistent
and um and you'll keep people keep
coming back to you to
to uh
figure it out and figure out a way to
get their films done so so
you know we we follow the demand and
follow that up with trying to figure out
a way to keep the supply
as close to what we want as possible but
we're still following the same
under the same laws
of supply and demand
what is the market for your movies and
how do they end up making money
well um we you know the lowest the kind
of medium to low budget action movies um
the market used to be
um kind of with the afm markets american
film market market
used to be straight to video
streaming
uh now it's mostly streaming um when we
create the films we we don't make these
films right now to be projected
um
one of the reasons is because some of
the best films now are not projected um
they're streamed
and um
so most of it's streaming uh it's coming
off of the old school video model
um you know which is a point of sale
model you know
perusing blockbuster and
that looks interesting let me grab it
you know now uh you're on streaming
platforms and so you look for
amazon netflix we have netflix films we
have amazon films hulu
2b
our films are everywhere
and and so
it still comes from the old system
though which is the
van damme
seagals world
of action films which is
it's formulaic a little bit the thing is
that we do
with mice films specifically is i add
this artistic tinge to them
um if you look at the reels and stuff
you'll see it um i try to do beautiful
beautiful framing center framing
things that are
to make the to make it look a little bit
bigger a little bit more beautiful a
little bit more composed
and not just you know shoot them up
action and knock them down action so i
do a lot of beautiful composition and
then i get a lot of really really good
performances
out of the uh actors
and but
at the end of the day you know they kind
of go into the same
streaming platforms amazon netflix
uh hulu
things like that and that's okay i think
that's where things are at now
so i don't think much is getting
projected these days i mean a lot
sometimes but i don't see films under 50
60 million dollars getting projected
that much and if so it's a no it's an
anomaly
and your distributor is approaching
these outlets to be hulu things like
that not not you personally no no the
distributor does that um when we hand it
off to the distributor they they send it
out among the world but usually they
have
because like i said before about
collateralization usually it's
collateralized in one way or the other
they already have
these people interested um and and
they're waiting for it a lot of times
and um
and so you know as long as the film
screens
good has a good trailer and is filmed as
is written
or close to it then it goes out on the
platforms and
you know these platforms are
subscription based so it's not i mean
they're going to get that subscription
whether they like my movie or not
they're still going to get their ten
dollars a month
so they need content
and um
and so the content um
and choice that's what people want you
can't have look the page and look at the
netflix page and there's four movies on
there they want choice
all the films aren't going to have the
same quality but
you know
they're
they have good relationships the
distributors and sales agents have good
relationships with these platforms and
they get it out there and it's always
nice to see them on there
can you explain what you mean by
collateralized
well collateralized meaning
the
money has to come through
collateralization process
which will be
that
the
distributor sales agent
will have to have sold or at least have
interested let's call it netflix or
amazon
in that movie to let's say a million
dollars or whatever or 500 000 and then
the other 500 000 they can sell in
foreign sales
you have to have a piece of paper
that they can take to a financial
institution that says
i'm going to sell 500 000 to this one
and i've already talked to them and they
see this and see that they've seen
they know the director
they know frazier's directing
they know what the subject matter is
they know that this actor is going to be
in it if it has those elements it has a
beginning middle and end
we'll buy it at this amount so they can
take all that the aggregate of all that
money that number and that creates the
collateral
and so then you take that package
collateral package to financier and the
financiers will look at it and say i'll
say okay the face of it is a million
dollars
meaning your collateral i'll give you
800 000.
some people would say i'll give you 500
000. others will say
i really like it i want you to make a
little bit bigger
i'll give you 1.2 million
so it depends on who you go to
but
everything has to be collateralized by
something if you're going to do it in
the traditional finance like i said if
you have the rich uncle then they'll
just take their chance or whatever if
you can do it
you know crowdfunding or something like
that but everything but if you but the
the more stable
environment to build a career on is to
be able to collateralize your projects
and your packages so that you can take
them out and get them financed and you
can figure out okay i can if i have this
element that element element that
element
this product is collateralized and now i
can just take it out to several
funding sources and figure out who wants
to do it
and with these funding sources where is
a filmmaker looking for
how to get in contact with these
individuals i mean it sounds like a lot
of these people they work with existing
it's not like
they just have a website where people
can just contact them well
um
my experience has been that that your
distributor knows who will quote bank
their paper
so when they say okay i'm gonna i your
film's worth this much they already have
a district a financier that knows them
they've already paid back several times
and so they already kind of have an open
deal they say okay so if um they come
there with the
fraser film that's a million dollars
worth of sales
or potential sales or whatever i'll give
80 of that they already know where to go
with that but there's also in kind of a
network of indie producers that we all
kind of use the same people a lot of
money comes out of the uk
um
you can just look it up and find people
but
you're always best whoever is giving you
collateral
should know who's going to
fund their collateral
that's how you know their collateral is
valuable
if somebody says if i go to you and say
hey i'm going to give you clowns i'm
going to give you a piece of paper and
say your film's worth a million dollars
people are going to say
who is this guy where what is he sold
what other collateral does he have is he
cross-collateralizing this with other
films blah blah blah so
so most so if you
a question for filmmakers to ask
uh producers is to ask
if you go to somebody and somebody gives
you a minimum guarantee
and you sign your film to do it with
them they give you a minute guarantee it
and you know whatever the amount is
first thing you ask them is who's who do
you know will bank your paper
because if your paper
your paper has to be bankable so you can
get it from somebody that no one will
bank the paper and then you've tied up
your movie for a year
so you ask them up front who banks your
paper they'll say well you can go to
citibank you can go to
this funding guy you can go to this
private equity fund and they fund that
and they funded our last four films so
we can go you know you send it out and
people send you a term sheet and they
you know they they bid for it the
funding companies bid for your
to fund the film
so first and foremost you were consumer
of action films before you started
making them so you knew the audience is
that right yeah a little bit i mean i i
like i said before i kind of got
turned into an action director because
that's where we are and that's what the
people distributors wanted
i tend to to have more um
my personal films i like tend to be more
um
epic and deep uh my favorite films are
like apocalypse now which has a lot of
action but it's also incredibly story
driven
um you know godfather um
movies like you know anything with dave
by david fincher
they have great action in them but
they're more story driven
and
you know
i think that where i'd like to end up
would be there
um
you know action films are great but you
know
you know in the big action films there's
a whole separate unit doing that you
know that's doing all that big stunts
and stuff
and sometimes they do it completely
independently
and the director you know worries about
the story and make sure the story ties
into everything
um so i'd like to do a film with no
action frankly that'd be that would be
my
because i've done so many with the
action and cartels and shooting
everybody up
i like to do one that just had um just a
story just a compelling
interesting story
that um you know something like a sling
blade you know was just a good story and
something that means something and maybe
inspires and
and people can
learn something from it and
feel good about it
and be part of
their artistic experience
so but but then i can't i don't want to
down action movies i mean they've done a
lot for me
and i've built a career on it so far
and um
i like doing those too you know i would
just would it's a balance and so i do
but but
in those in the films we do there's we
sneak that story in we sneak it in so
that it's there so that
so that that's what keeps that train
moving and that that trajectory towards
um
more exactly what i want i don't want to
just
you know capitulate to doing action all
the time i want to want to create that
story in there and the in the framing
and the cinematography and all that
stuff so that it's a little bit more
than just the average action film i hope